but it's only right because we need to
talk about all the other twitch drama
that's going on so which has been
serving the best reality show Jude it's
wild it's it it really is a full-on
reality show just by itself the amount
of [ __ ] drama is juicy yeah it's I
mean I mean that's why that's why people
love the just chatting IRL category
because it has so much there's so so so
much drama in that way shout out the
live stream fails
the journalists of the twitch community
look in anyway so yeah I don't know what
you want to start with because there's
so much to and and and you don't even
have to be a twitch like consumer to
really get into this [ __ ] because it
it's so good man well that's the thing
like these people are all like like just
huge celebrities on their own right now
I don't even feel like do you think
people probably no doubt doctor
disrespect even if you don't watch him
on twitch you know of him you know that
he's the biggest streamer same with
Ninja I don't think so man I think
actually no I think doctor disrespect
he's got a specific type of notoriety
about argue it's still pretty internet
heavy yeah Ninja is been on like a SNL
and weird NBC shows like people know
ninja target knows ninja you know what I
mean yeah and that's know doc on doctor
disrespect but so I'm you know you know
what's your theory okay so just for
everyone who doesn't know because these
names sound like wrestler names as far
as anyone else is concerned it's also
hilarious to be a grown man named ninja
I'm pretty sure I've said that before
that is so funny to be thirty years old
and it is really funny actually called
ninja I was I was explaining doctor
disrespects thing to someone who wasn't
involved or like you know who doesn't
know about streaming at all they don't
get it and I was like yet and they were
like wait it's a character and I was
like yeah he's like so he puts on the
the wig and the aviators like every time
in the costume and I was like yeah and
they were like
yes I just do that every day that's his
job putting on a costume and I was like
yeah what do you mean I hate how people
say that like that's not a thing in TV
well [ __ ] I mean I guess the
immediate examples I go to our children
shows but that's besides the point
it is kind of funny I'm sorry go putting
on like a yeah you know it's like that
yeah yeah yeah no but it's everyday it's
not like a shoot it's like every day all
day what I mean you know whatever method
I think it's amazing I think it's
hilarious
I think he's so goddamn funny
he's hilarious and I mean the stream
production is out of this [ __ ] world
I [ __ ] as so much respect for that
gender Marcus link me a clip of from a
stream recently where he's like he's
like watching a trailer for some new
game yeah it's like he pauses and he's
like to to imagine playing this on
console yeah that's my 350 thousand
dollar PC and then someone in someone in
his chat was bugging him and he was like
he was like What did he say he said
something about you're probably an
accountant for a company you don't even
own I mean while I'm driving 10 Lambos
dude when when he was roasting that kid
he's like he's like 5 views 7 views quit
quit
I forget at what point in that in that
segment or the sequence where he he goes
on reddit he's like how could you
imagine going on reddit you're at the
bottom of the barrel upvoting posts
talking to people what is your life I
was crying dude so if you don't know
he's one of the biggest streamers doing
it for like a decade now and he got
banned just out of the blue nobody knows
why
that's the weirdest part is they didn't
nobody has said no
zero people know why yeah and sponsors
keep doing weird thing and he's got big
sponsors man like Mountain Dew and
whatever you know they they like raiser
you know they they took down pages
featuring his endorsements and they put
them back up and then they took him back
down again so everyone is staring at
that thinking what the [ __ ] you know man
it's crazy and people never hit it
no no you're fine no you're fine no no
good well you might be thinking if you
don't know you know about streaming or
whatever you may be thinking well what's
the big deal like you started a stream
people will follow you and or start on a
different website or whatever but they
have exclusive contracts you know he's
on a multi-million dollar exclusive
contract to stream on Twitch you know he
makes millions a year just from
streaming yeah all the endorsements all
the subscriptions he has on twitch he's
spent a decade building up his audience
on Twitch all to have that just be
removed in a second mm-hmm like so that
ended everything yeah nobody knows why
well the only update that he gave is
that twitch didn't give him a reason so
there's a clip of a dude who I think he
used to be a twitch admin and I don't
know his name I feel bad for not knowing
his name but he basically he I think
used to be an employee at twitch either
way he's sitting there and he's really
conflicted he says I really want to talk
about this but I can't he said the only
thing I can say is that if you get a ban
twitch usually doesn't give you a reason
as to why it's it's not it's not
required if you're suspended I think
it's a bit different or if you get a
temporary ban but a permanent ban you're
not always
a reason so either you know what you did
or it was reported by a third party so
that's what makes it weirder so does
someone have something on him and got
him banned or is it something that doc
is doing and he knows he's doing and
he's playing dumb that's what makes it
weird what could it be though so so to
make it interesting because everyone is
like why the [ __ ] do I care about this
so what what some in his last stream
what made it really bizarre for people
was he was just acting super odd it's
the final 8 minutes of the stream and
yeah his phone and he gets kind of
choked up and he starts referencing this
weird right-wing conspiracy theorist and
he's like screaming strange [ __ ] like
wake up and you know there's a final 30
seconds he has this behavior where it
seems like he he physically reacts to
like the same action you would do if you
heard a loud noise and and he abruptly
ends a stream he kind of looks to his
left and right and goes [ __ ] and then he
ends the stream so people were
speculating oh maybe he knew he was
getting arrested and the police were
showing up and it was like in the middle
of them coming and he knew they were on
their way to pick him up some goofy [ __ ]
like that and you know that was kind of
an but the big one that caught my eye
and and I think maybe has legs is people
are speculating that him ninja and
Shroud because ninja and Shroud are no
longer at mixer they got the big payday
and now they're off
yeah they speculate that the three of
them were maybe setting up to create a
streaming platform with Google and so
they think there could be some weirdness
there where
maybe doc got caught recruiting people
and I read something that you know this
guy claimed to be like a former twitch
ITV / saw that - that for Campos yeah
and and he I don't know I don't think I
saw it from 4chan it was like
paraphrased somewhere but basically yeah
he was saying that he thinks that Google
is setting up to sue the [ __ ] out of
twitch and maybe it'll be some weird
legal battle I haven't seen any tweets
about like motions filed or anything and
this guy likes war is like Monday you're
gonna see these documents so maybe
they're there and I haven't seen them
but I would have known nothing happened
yeah I would assume slasher would have
said something so doesn't seem like it's
gonna be that so I don't know and it's
it's just ambiguous it's also like why
would Google create their own streaming
platform right as Microsoft is shutting
theirs down yeah yeah like right as
Microsoft is like we can't compete with
- money's not worth it for us yeah
doesn't really mate or maybe it makes
more sense at that point for them for
them to do it but but that post also
said it was a joint effort between
Spotify and Google - which makes no
[ __ ] sense says you don't like
somebody just making some [ __ ] up that
that hoping that people reshare it yeah
I mean I don't yeah that that part of it
I think is right but you know this is
just so juicy though yeah it may it
makes you wonder what the [ __ ] is going
on because then you're everyone's mind
goes the other way what [ __ ] up [ __ ]
could he have been doing to get ban you
know the immediate because he got he
cheated on his wife before yeah and that
was a big deal so but you know like
getting banned for that would that's a
personal thing right I mean they can win
free stuff off platform now their twitch
is kind of taking it you know upon
themselves - I think they're just trying
to remove anything that
era is like super controversial I think
I think they really I want to get away
from that yeah they just say but you
know what their whole Safety Council
thing I don't know you can't call it
though because they're so inconsistent
so you don't really know what the [ __ ]
they're doing but either way I mean I
don't I wish I had jokes about this [ __ ]
but I'm really just drawn in I want to
know you I want to know I just want to
know I want to know what the [ __ ] is
good because he was one of the most
admired figures on on Twitch no yeah and
just on social media in general like
just what he's accomplished huh and
stuff in like just his his content and
his audience and it was just everything
he was great and now all of a sudden
just gone yeah and what nobody knows why
it's so bizarre I mean it just wanted to
say flex it makes me feel like such a
smooth brain that I care so much and I
can't see any humor in it or I can't
generate a joke but it's it's [ __ ]
bizarre and they're you know that a lot
of people are speculating that he's
doing time you know like he's in jail or
something right now and that's why he's
not talking and there's no update and as
this what the [ __ ] Wow Wow well this is
an endorsement so what if he's dead oh
here we go
what if he's dead yeah and then he comes
back his evil doctor disrespect on
Facebook gaming for 20 trillion dollars
same thing but he's just got a red
mullet yeah
looking like dr. Robotnik yeah I want to
know I really want to know yeah doc if
you're if you're listening to this if
you're just hitting a DM we won't tell
anyone
we're just text me bro hit us up man
it's been a while yeah I'll talk to my
number on the podcast just so I could
you know get some confirmation from you
I'm in this Kyle let's get Kyle to get
him on the show yeah and he'll revealed
everyone why he got banned on TMG bro
he's a big [ __ ] you seen that
guy
six-eight yes heute ridiculous yeah man
he used to he used to Marcus said he
goes by to time because he won he won a
dunk contest when he was like 14 or
something yeah
his high school dunk contest you don't
like that and then he wanted again the
next year and so now he goes by two-time
champion I mean bro the whole funny all
right I remember watching doc you know
you know way back when when twit twitch
was in infancy but it was it was
starting to become a bit more mainstream
I remember this lady he's the first dude
I said seen with that much production
value and I thought holy [ __ ] man the
commitment to this is yeah Zayn he's
such a spectacle even were all his
mistakes he's such a spectacle so I want
that [ __ ] I don't know what's
happening with this guy I really hope
it's not something shitty I really hope
it's I don't know well he well there was
like there was a kind of an interesting
clip on on critical he did a video on it
yes like clips from his stream like
pretty recently where he's talking about
buying a whole bunch of this these weird
rocks that apparently like negate 5g
frequencies and like conspiracy
theorists [ __ ] okay it was a little bit
weird and so people I guess like one of
the one of the theories is that they
banned him because he was like spreading
misinformation to the OU audience who is
a pretty young he didn't want people you
know his young audience like starting to
go vandalize 5g towers because all of
sudden they think it gives you [ __ ]
care or whatever right I mean it could
be a dude it could be that simple
but it might not be anything that it
could be something like that yeah that's
not a permanent ban that's like a hey
stop doing that you would think but who
knows that's I'm like trying to figure
something funny to say about this whole
thing but it's it's just wild to have
your whole career ripped out from
underneath you in a second the weirdest
part about is that they refunded
but he subs when would they ever do that
twitch loves taking money so what I was
like we're I would they give all that
money back middle they love taking that
money dude Malusi [ __ ] get
banned they don't get their subs don't
get refunded this is oh yeah he got
banned he [ __ ] up but thanks yeah
all of that is ours now yeah we know you
paid for four weeks of content but it's
fine you're just gonna get to this month
and take it out on the creator and
stress him the [ __ ] out make him feel
like [ __ ] for his mistake it's
definitely his fault nothing to do with
us so thanks for the money
and get [ __ ] yep yeah exactly
that's Twitch's that's their slogan
thank you money get [ __ ] yeah
you